so the more we look at polling the more
we might think that joe biden and kamala
harris have this election in the bag but
consider for a moment that
even if the polls are both perfectly
accurate and don't change
between now and election day what about
voter suppression
because the supreme court just showed us
that at least
three of the justices are more than
willing
to throw out absentee ballots and that
is not
priced into the polls in any way the
supreme court has reinstated
south carolina's witness signature
requirement
for absentee ballots they did this
earlier this week
that alone is a decision that could
decide whether lindsey graham
is re-elected as a republican incumbent
in south carolina
or whether challenger jamie harrison
from the democratic party
removes incumbent lindsey graham that is
what the stakes are here and it means
that south carolinians including those
infected with coronavirus will once
again
need witnesses to sign their ballot
envelopes so think that through for a
second you have coronavirus or you want
to avoid getting it you have it and want
to avoid spreading it or you shouldn't
go out
or you want to avoid getting it from
someone else you just want to be as safe
as possible
you request an absentee ballot beautiful
you get the absentee ballot
perfect you fill out the absentee ballot
correctly
lovely but before you send it in you
need to find a witness
to sign the envelope for you that says
it's really you voting it's really you
sending this thing in
it's pointless because that signature
could of course be forged
it risks spreading the virus and it will
almost
certainly lead to the nullification of
ballots
but that's not the worst of it it's even
worse
potentially because justices clarence
thomas
samuel alito and neil gorsuch would have
been willing not just to say that
these ballots going forward must have a
witness signature
but thomas alito and gorsuch actually
were ready to say
this rule should be applied
retroactively so
i really need people to understand this
clarence thomas samuel alito and neil
gorsuch
would be on board with saying ballots
already received by south carolina
election officials
before this decision was made about
witness signatures
those ballots should be thrown out even
though at the time that folks sent their
ballots in
this uh witness signature rule was not
yet the rule
it is outrageous and extreme and what it
signals to me is that
if indeed they get amy coney barrett
confirmed to the supreme court
and if indeed this entire presidential
election
starts to extend into november and
starts to
involve courts there are already three
amy coney barrett could be a fourth and
then you then it's just a question mark
what will john roberts do what will
others do
they are willing to actually interfere
in ways that are material these are not
theoretical things these are not things
that might have an impact but two or
four years from now this is right now
and had they gotten this rule past the
retroactive
requirement for witness signatures that
would have led to
i don't even know how many ballots being
thrown out that could have led
to lindsey graham winning even if jamie
harrison would otherwise have won i mean
we don't know that's going to be a tight
race and it's an uphill battle for jamie
harrison
but the point here is the trump
administration
is going to use this to their advantage
in any way that they can the trump
campaign has an army of lawyers ready to
do
anything they can in any state they can
do it to see what they can get away with
biden has a team of lawyers but are they
ready
as i've said before it's much more
difficult to play defense
because you need to anticipate every
strategy that trump can use trump might
have 10 different
strategies lawyers will use and biden's
lawyers might anticipate nine of them
and it could be that tenth one
that actually gets you in the end so
they really need to be prepared because
trump wants to win
trump at this point can only win
by preventing people from voting by
dissuading people from voting
by having people's votes not counted and
republicans have repeatedly said in
public that this is the plan
no one should be surprised now that they
are actually making the plan
a reality and if it comes to just a
couple of states
which it might and the supreme court
invalidates
hundreds of thousands of votes more than
that
will there be a revolt i actually think
you know i i
don't have uh i have what i think is a
realistic assessment that most people
can't afford to miss the next day of
work and most people are not going to
mass rally and go protest because
they have people to feed and money to
make and bills to pay and i understand
that
but i actually think that if it appears
as though
a supreme court with multiple justices
on it selected by donald trump
in starts invalidating votes and
potentially flips the election to trump
i do believe there will be complete
actual chaos in the streets i believe we
will see mass rallies i
i do believe that and i rarely am of
that mindset let me know what you think
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video